hey y'all uh what's up my name is Cohn
I'm here reacting to the Donovan
Mitchell trade which came out of
legitimately nowhere I was like half
asleep on my couch about like an hour
hour and a half ago when the trade news
broke uh came from woj who you know when
you look at the tweet at the top it
doesn't show the full thing and I just
saw Donovan Mitchell trade and you know
I thought it was more trade rumors like
we've seen over and over again but
instead Donovan Mitchell is heading to
the Cleveland Cavaliers and what was a
complete shock to me I know we had seen
like the Knicks or the main team of the
Charlotte Hornets the Washington Wizards
had been mentioned here and there but it
kind of seemed like it was a conclusion
at this point that he was going to end
up as a New York Knick I know a lot of
Knicks fans putting them in Jersey swaps
and stuff like that even the Miami Heat
apparently like a rumor came out today
that he was rumored to you know like
what Miami had going on there he wanted
to play there but no he's ending up in
Cleveland which is an insane move one
that I think is super exciting you know
there was the whole Kevin Durant
situation that didn't end up in a trade
you know Kyrie Irving didn't get moved
so Donovan Mitchell was kind of the last
Domino to fall or potentially the only
Domino to fall at this point in the off
season so I'm super psyched about it
excited to be here talking with you all
about what's going on with this trade
we've got some people in the chat of
course easy saying that the Cavs are
winning the East uh the cows are looking
really good I'm really excited about
their future
um of course the Utah Jazz heading into
their rebuild after you know go Baron
Donovan Mitchell that pairing didn't end
up working out the way they hoped to
they had a couple decent playoff runs
but nothing insane and they are
completely having a fire sale right now
Pat Bev got traded last week to the Los
Angeles Lakers uh gobert of course weeks
before to the Timberwolves where they
got a billion draft picks and now even
more draft picks coming from this past
trade just a lot of stuff going down
over there in Utah uh the Brian
windhorst meme comes into play right now
a ton I'm just really excited though of
course as an NBA fan one of the most
exciting Parts is all the roster
movement and young teams and a team like
the Cavaliers making this huge move
after years of it really just being kind
of the LeBron James show you know they
hadn't won much at all without LeBron
now they're building kind of an identity
of their own which is really exciting
this Cavaliers team is going to be super
super fun I'm excited to see what they
do uh the Jazz you know heading into
this full rebuild section of their kind
of era moving on from Donovan Mitchell
who was such a big piece of their
identity for so long and Rudy gobert but
here we go we're heading into a new era
for both of these teams and there is a
lot to talk about and go into with these
trades of course you know breaking down
the trade packages for both sides we saw
you know Colin Sexton was involved in it
him and Darris Garland no longer being
together in that backcourt
um the Jazz now you know what does this
mean for them in terms of the rest of
the players on their roster because they
still have a lot of really good players
on that roster uh as you can see here
we've got now um the Chris Haynes tweet
that revealed the full package uh he was
the first one to kind of get the full
thing so we've got Cleveland sending
Lori Market in Colin Sexton akbaji and
it was 3 future first round picks in
2025 2027 and 2029 plus two draft pick
swaps to the Utah Jazz for Donovan
Mitchell to pair Darius Garland and
Donovan Mitchell in the backcourt one of
the best back courts in the league there
are very few back courts that you can
even make an argument for that is better
than the two of those guys and when we
take a look at the Cavs full roster it
is uh it is absolutely insane I believe
I've got a tweet pulled up here Darius
Garland Donovan Mitchell Karis Levert
Evan Mobley Jared Allen Kevin Love Isaac
accoro Yeti Osmond Ricky Rubio Dean Wade
um just a ridiculous roster this is such
a good team and probably the most
exciting part about it is you know
they're still super young this was a
trade that you know there were a lot of
rumors about him going to the Knicks
potentially I didn't love that
personally just because I thought well
him going to the Knicks would have been
fun you know you've got Brunson now in
the mix with things RJ Barrett is Young
so is Mitchell Robinson they didn't
really have like the young you know like
like a guy like Evan Mobley who still
could become like a superstar down the
line or Darius Garland was already like
that Bonafide All-Star to me a place
like Cleveland makes a ton of sense to
send Mitchell and you know a team to
trade for Mitchell because you add on to
another Young Star to what is already a
young core and a team that could compete
for a really long time this trade also
completely broke Twitter
um as you can see here this tweet of
mine it completely broke the it
completely broke the entire app like it
was ridiculous
um there really wasn't like you couldn't
refresh tweets you couldn't like figure
anything out
um it was just ridiculous
um we got some people in the chat here
uh we've got uh smoothie who says about
a bet my house that the Cavs have win
the East uh um maybe save it on the
house a little bit we'll talk about
maybe their title chances in a second
um just real talk said I personally
think Mitchell's overrated but it's a
great fit with the team
um you know we can talk a little bit
about Mitchell you know his shortcomings
and kind of some of the concerns with
the Cavaliers but I do think I agree it
is a great fit with the team um Donovan
Mitchell as you can see here I'm giving
the two exclamation points
um above Darius Garland tweeting out
about the two of them teaming up
together
um AG says the Cavs are not better than
the heat Buck sixes or Nets they're not
top four
um that doesn't include the Celtics who
are also really good which I think shows
how stacked the East is but the
Cavaliers to me have kind of you know
while Donovan Mitchell makes them
compete now something that I think is
really exciting about this move is yeah
sure they're you know maybe they don't
end up winning the East this year but
they're a team that has so much young
Talent they can compete for years like
Darius Garland is I still believe 23
years old at this point 22 Evan Moby's
heading into just his second season
Jared Allen just hit All-Star caliber
level uh it is a really young team in
general so it's not like you know they
added this piece and they're you know
hoping that he's the guy that's going to
push them over the top like right right
now it's something that could you know
be a few years in the making we've also
got
um Darth Husker saying that the Cavs
gave up too much well something that I
think we got to keep in mind here is yes
they gave up the picks are the huge
thing and really we've seen this massive
rise in picks being traded ever since
that Thunder Clippers trade where Kawhi
Leonard and Paul George went to uh you
know the Clippers through the Paul
George trip through the Thunder which
got them Kawhi Leonard so they gave up a
million draft picks and ever since that
trade draft picks have been flying off
the shelves we saw the go bear trade
have a ridiculous amount of picks traded
um so there is a lot of opportunity
there to trade draft picks and stuff but
in terms of what they gave up if we go
back to the Chris Haynes tweet here you
know Colin Sexton wasn't on their team
outside of like 11 games last season it
was a really great season for them and
he didn't even play so he really wasn't
in their plans anymore you know agbaji
is a really fun player but he also
wasn't there last season he would have
brought some nice 3D play to the the
team but he wasn't on that super
successful season that we saw last year
so I don't think that's a massive loss
for them necessarily
um Lori marketing of course was there
last year and he was integral to their
success but I think Donovan Mitchell you
know he's a clear upgrade in terms of
star player output in you know over Lori
marketing you know we'll have to figure
out without the scheme fits and
everything like that but I just I they
did give up a lot but I feel like it's
an incredible trade for them I think it
really does a lot for this team and
really benefits them
um like we saw here Donovan Mitchell and
Derek scarlin clearly pretty excited to
play together
um we go back and look at their roster
um like I said you know they've got
Garland Mitchell in the backcourt one of
the best in the league they still got
Karis Levert who they added at the trade
deadline this past year he was pretty
solid uh over the course of last season
and I expect now having the fall off
season to kind of grow and have some
more time to mold together uh you've got
Evan Mobley who I have said a million
times if you don't know I'm a huge Evan
mobile I think Mobley has potential to
be a superstar in the league I think he
has Anthony Davis type potential he's a
guy that could be a defensive player of
the year down the line and all defensive
player uh he can stretch the floor he
can handle the ball he does everything
and the fact that you know now he has
not just Garland who is a phenomenal
playmaker but Donovan Mitchell who also
is a underrated playmaker to get him the
ball and put him in spots to succeed I
think it's going to be really cool for
his game
um you know Jared Allen
um Kevin Love Isaac accoro Jetty Osmond
Ricky Rubin like they've got depth to
Kevin Love is a guy that you know was in
Sixth Man the year conversations Ricky
Rubio prior to getting hurt was bawling
out for them he was he hit like what
like eight threes in Madison Square
Garden which was ridiculous uh he was
really really fun um you know they've
got a bunch of guys that could make some
upgrades here and there but I love this
roster uh for me this great for the Cavs
this is like an A plus this is an
incredible trade for the Cavaliers I
really I can't I can't talk a much like
enough about how much I like it
um we've got tmac saying this was the
best possible upgrade by the Cavs I
think I really agree I think they did an
incredible job uh we've got Adrian
saying that the Cavs are not making the
playoffs uh I I completely disagree uh
they if you remember they were a
they were a team that was like towards
the top of the East before they had a
bunch of injuries at the end of the year
like Mobly missed time you know Jared
Allen missed some time too they were a
team that had so much great play last
season but now you know they've got
another year to grow and they've added
Donovan Mitchell it's good I would be
shocked if they didn't make the playoffs
um Thomas says Knicks blew it again
chalk up another L for them I you know
of course like adding Donovan Mitchell
makes them better but I personally think
it's all right that they didn't get
Donovan Mitchell uh you know they just
locked up RJ Barrett long term and to me
Donovan Mitchell felt like it might be
capping them out a little bit uh now
they've got you know more room to kind
of let this young team grow Mitchell I
think would have put them in that middle
ground where they're not necessarily a
contender you know they're not a great
playoff team but they're pretty solid so
I think now this gives them some more
opportunity in what's a loaded Eastern
Conference I think they'll be once again
probably a team that ends up at the edge
of the lottery that playing kind of area
and I think they could be really good
um you know moving on and terms of
you know their future it's a stacked
draft class we've got Victor Wen benyama
we've got
um scoot Henderson another great
Prospect in the draft too a lot of
things going on that's really good
um let's see what else we've got here in
the chat uh John says factscone Moby
ceiling is off the charts this team is
going to be scary I completely agree
I've seen a lot of people say they're a
bit concerned about the defense um you
know Garland and Mitchell neither of
them are great Defenders but the fact
that they've got Mobley and Allen I
think really elevates this team a lot
Mobley like I said as a guy that I think
could be all defensive as soon as next
year uh you know you've got Jared Allen
who's a great room protector Isaac
accoro is a solid perimeter Defender as
well Charis Levert can play solid on
that and too they've got guys they can
you know switch and move around
depending on what they need and I think
having those two guys download Mobley
and Alan kind of eliminates a lot of my
concerns there
um we've got
um we who says that the cows are gonna
be a four seed at least uh it's really
exciting you know I think right now the
top teams in the East are like the
Celtics we've got the Sixers and we've
got the Milwaukee Bucks the Miami Heat
or in the that conversation too but I
think losing PJ Tucker kind of hurt them
a good bit so we'll see how they're able
to if they make any more moves to kind
of fill that whole lot power forward but
I think the Cavs are right there in that
mix you know with the Heat and the Nets
to try and go for like that four or five
spot uh you know we just have to see how
those young guys play together
um we've got
um nappy Kerr who's saying y'all really
think the Cavs got better but they're
still the same I completely disagree
Mitchell gives them a whole nother
Dynamic another great scorer and a guy
who can you know handle the ball create
shots Garland sometimes last year was
forced to create a lot more and it kind
of made them one-dimensional at times
offensively I think Donovan Mitchell
helps out a ton with that AJ Hamilton
says Cavs and easy lock for the playoffs
now I agree
um then we've got a couple people who
are talking about the Utah Jazz uh luaz
uh says r.i.p.u Todd Jazz yeah rest in
peace to this era and sleeve saying that
the Jazz won this trade I think so let's
get into a little bit about the Utah
Jazz let's move over to the Jazz portion
of this real quick to kind of give them
you know let's go over what they're
going to look like now
um so let's go over to a tweet here that
talks about
um the Utah Jazz and what they've built
up in terms of assets through this
gobert and Donovan Mitchell trade um you
know like like we said they got
marketing agbaji Sexton in three first
round picks and two swaps I think this
was a pretty good trade for the Jazz in
terms of getting assets towards their
rebuild I give it probably like a B plus
I think that you know there was talk of
could they get like a queen Grimes or an
RJ Barrett and while they didn't get one
of those guys Sexton was really good
prior to injury he averaged 24 points
per game a couple years ago of course
that injury is a bit of a concern but
he's a solid Young Piece that they can
either build around or they can now go
ahead towards the future and you know
maybe they end up trading him down the
line which is the big thing we need to
talk about with the Jazz if we look here
at this tweet I'm coming from wob at the
time of this tweet here's what Utah got
for Donovan Mitchell and go bear Malik
Beasley tht Stanley Johnson Leandro
balmaro Walker Kessler Vanderbilt Morgan
and ibaji Sexton 2023 first round pick
225 first run picks two swaps in 2026
two first round picks in 2027 a 2028
swap a 29 first round pick and now we've
they've got assets like Jordan Clarkson
bogdanovic Mike Conley you know they've
still got so many guys Malik Beasley
they could even trade there's so many
different guys that they could trade to
get more assets and if we look at stat
Muse
I'm a thunder fan if you didn't know so
I know a lot about draft picks the Jazz
now have we talk so much about how many
draft picks the Thunder have in the next
few years the Jazz are now tied in terms
of the next seven drafts in draft picks
they have built this up and honestly
they're gonna pass Us in terms of assets
once the bogdanovich trade happens once
a Conley trade happens uh there is so
much so many more moves to still happen
for them to work towards this rebuild
this isn't like their first level like
there's so much more that could happen
and now I think it made a lot of sense
to get Donovan Mitchell out of the team
for right now because you know him being
there is only going to make you a bit
better he's not going to stay long term
it makes sense to deal him for right now
and eventually you know just move on to
the new era which I think the Jazz
deserve a ton of credit for uh we've got
all the smokes and Clarkson sex on the
same team nobody's passing the ball
um I don't think Clarkson's going to be
there too long uh yeah the Jazz aren't
going to be great this upcoming season
you're not wrong
um we've got yeah ehunt saying that the
Jazz made the right choice I agree uh
they had to move on you know gobert and
Mitchell they gave them their run they
made a couple decent runs they looked
solid and it just it didn't end up being
enough to make it over the hump so they
said okay you know this air is over
we're gonna go ahead and capitalize now
rather than trying to run it back this
next year and they fall off a little bit
and their trade value goes down they
trade these two guys at their Peak trade
value and that's something that's really
hard to do in the NBA a lot of teams
will just stick with the team way too
long and then you don't get the assets
and you wasted a bunch of years it just
doesn't end up working out
um shed Hunter says that Mitchell was a
diva glad he's gone hashtag take notes
um if you're a jazz fan you're the first
jazz fan I've seen say that I don't know
if that's a sentiment across the jazz
fan base I've seen a lot of
um Jasmine's pretty upset about this uh
I know as a thunder fan if I saw like
Shay get traded it would be a real
heartbreak or so my heart goes out to
you Jazz fans I know it sucks to see
your team go into a rebuild
um watching Russell West uppercut traded
for example was a heartbreaker for me
but eventually you know it is the right
move that you have to make
um Kevin says that the Jazz robbed two
teams blind in the same off-season they
got a ton of picks like it was
ridiculous the amount of assets that
they added through this whole thing uh
Eli Gardner says Jazz are stacked Loki I
don't know if you mean right now or for
the future I'm gonna assume you mean for
the future uh because right now not a
great team but in terms of future assets
you know like they they've got Sexton
they've got Jared Vanderbilt who's a
really fun Young Piece too
um Taylor Horton Tucker I'm excited to
see what he does and kind of a more
expanded and a lot less pressure-filled
role you know he doesn't have to
immediately contribute on a championship
team it's a rebounding Squad they got
Walker Kessler who was just a first
round pick I believe Beasley's still
pretty young but they could still flip
him I'm sure they'll get more young
assets too from flipping those guys
alongside picks the Jazz are going to be
a really interesting team to keep up
with now there's a ton of different ways
they can go with this rebuild and I'm
excited to see you know how they decide
to go do they decide to hold on to their
pieces you know like a couple of the
young guys do they just go full out
trade them immediately before training
camp do they wait till the deadline uh
wise Brad is saying who's the leading
scorer in Utah next season it's going to
be calling Sexton I would imagine
um I'm not sure it would be kind of fun
to see sex and just go out there and put
up like 30 points per game you know just
trade the rest the guys let sex and hoop
see what he's able to put together and
just kind of let him um you know make
things happen
we'll see what happens with him
um because there's not really many
scores other than him on the team uh you
know you've got uh like like we talked
about Jordan Clarkson but I think he'll
you know end up getting moved to a
contender as a six-man I think he's a
super valuable piece uh but yeah so
we'll see what happens with Sexton and
the Jazz
um there are other teams like we talked
about that were kind of in the
conversation with the Jazz uh other
trade packages out there
um the Wizards and hornets were two
teams that were kind of rumored but we
never heard about what package they
specifically thought about offering
which doesn't surprise me they didn't
have a ton of assets either of those
teams and it didn't really make sense to
me once again kind of similar to the
Knicks situation where I didn't really
feel like he would have elevated either
of those teams enough
um but when we talk about the New York
Knicks because I know there are a lot of
Knicks fans that are really sad about
this I once again want to say I think I
think this is fine for the Knicks I
think that they are a team that is kind
of still in that middle ground you know
adding Donovan Mitchell did it would it
make me them immediate Contender I still
feel like they're looking for more
pieces through the draft and now I think
they're a team that will probably end up
missing the Playoffs they'll be right
there on that cusp you know if all
things break right if RJ Barrett
improves a lot maybe they make a playoff
run but I think that they'll probably be
in the play into the lottery and that
gives them the chance to you know go get
a great draft pick in what is a stacked
draft class something else that helps
with the Jazz you know why they decided
to go all out and give everything up
this year this draft class is completely
stacked uh so the Jazz uh going all in
made sense and with the New York Knicks
you know now they're just kind of in
that like they're still kind of in the
same spot they didn't have to give up a
million draft picks uh which a lot of
people were concerned about because
there was rumors that they were going to
try and get the Knicks like like four
future first round picks four pick swaps
like Quentin Grimes Obi top and like
they wanted all of their pieces and that
to me just felt like it would be a
ridiculous amount uh so I don't know I
think the Knicks did fine I'm gonna give
the Knicks like like a b maybe um of
course Donovan Mitchell would have made
them better but I think the fact that
they held that they stuck to their guns
and they didn't give up you know way
more than they wanted to give up they
were like this is our offer they didn't
you know they didn't give up all of
their assets when they didn't feel that
they needed to so I applaud them for
sticking to their guns on that uh Jay
smoothie says as a Knicks fan life is
pretty hard right now
um yeah I mean you've got Jalen Brunson
who's excited you just locked up R.J
Barrett young term or long term who is
still a young piece a really exciting
player I think he's in for a really good
season uh excited to see what he can do
you know Obi toppen uh Mitchell Robinson
like Quinn Grimes too I think is an
incredible Young Piece he looked way too
good for the summer league out there so
I think you know I think the Knicks are
going to be perfectly fine
um zivi says Knicks fans already down
bad though like they're the Knicks uh
funback I'm actually live streaming
right here from New York right now so uh
maybe later I'll go outside and see if I
can figure out what some Knicks fans are
feeling about this whole thing
um you know we'll see uh definitely have
to check out some Knicks games and see
how they're filming about the Donovan
Mitchell situation uh when the Cavaliers
come to town
um let's see we've got
um the the underdog or under dqg is
saying Nicks are just the Browns of the
NBA um
I don't know that's kind of a tough
comparison I guess in term if you mean
like you know how did they you know are
they trying to build a better team stuff
like that
um we've got a tweet from Bleach report
that I'm gonna pull up real quick to uh
go over about this
um go over with the trade obviously pull
up the account real quick
um we've got
we've got uh write this backcourt so
we've got Darius Garland and Donovan
Mitchell
I I don't know it is it is a really good
backcourt
um like we talked about there aren't a
lot of got like backwards immediately
coming to mind that can compete with you
know this backcourt we've got some of
the you know Steph and clay have been
one of the better backwards for a while
uh Tyrese Maxi and James Harden uh we've
got
um dejante Murray and Trey young are a
backward that's pretty good you know
you've got Marcus Smart Jalen Brown
there's some really good backcourts but
Garland and SP and spider are two legit
All-Stars you know David Mitchell's an
all-nba caliber player I think Darris
Garland could get there at some point
not too far away he was ridiculous last
season so they're they're really good
like off the top of my head there were
very few backwards at all that I think
are you know better than this backcourt
you know they might be the best one next
season we could very well see that and I
think they're a great pairing I know
some people in chat have voice concerns
about their defense alongside each other
I I think that Mobley and Alan kind of
cover that up they've got okoro they've
got Levert
um AJ Hamilton's saying I just know
Mitchell is excited to go from Utah of
all places to Cleveland I'm sure they
cleared this with him before the trade
there's no way they would have traded
Donovan Mitchell somewhere that he
didn't want to go I wouldn't imagine
they would have
um under dqg uh earlier talking about
the Knicks being the Browns uh there's
been straight DVD movies that have had
more success than the Knicks you know
it's been a while let's not go too hard
on the Knicks here you know they they
don't deserve all this
um Zibby says the Cavs second round exit
at best
I mean well that's the thing this isn't
just for now and that's I guess that's
kind of the point I want to hit on here
as we start to close things out it's not
just the trade for now part of the
reason I love this trade so much is
because it helps them in the future too
Mitchell's locked up for a few seasons
Garland's locked up uh Jared Allen is
under contract Evan Mobley is just
entering his second season it's not like
like say you had a contending team that
traded for Kevin Durant for example and
now it's like okay he's 34 years old
you've got to win a championship now
Donovan Mitchell's still really young he
hasn't even hit his prime yet based on
when most players do and so we've you
know you've got him you've got Garland
Mobley Allen like I believe it was uh
this Danny Cunningham tweet real quick
that we can take a look at
uh the Caps have three All-Stars under
the age of 26 and not a single one of
them is Evan Mobley who in my opinion
could end up being the best player on
that team like they are so set for the
future it is insane I know some people
have been talking about the whole LeBron
James the Cleveland reunion you know if
he came back now that would be even more
insane he did sign that extension with
the Lakers though so probably not but
just something to kind of think about a
little bit there so I love it for the
Cavs I think this was an incredible job
by their general manager putting
together a team that can compete for not
just now but the long term I'm super
excited to see what it looks like and
for the Jazz I think it's a win for them
too they continue their rebuild they
traded Donovan Mitchell and Rudy gobert
while their values were still high they
got a ton of picks out of it as we saw
you know they have 15 first round picks
in the next seven drafts they're gonna
be great I really think that they
um I I really think that they're able to
you know really look forward towards
their future right now I think that they
have a ton to look forward to Jazz fans
I'm sure it's hard uh but I promise
things will be okay the Jazz will make
it back you know if you all get like
Victor webiniana or scoot Henderson this
upcoming draft you will be fine um AJ
Hamilton adding that the Cavs got some
tiny men in that backcourt man
I think it'll be good you know they've
got two seven Footers in the front Court
to kind of even that out
um the Cavs have run some fun laps you
know that Laurie Market in last year as
this like almost seven footer at the
small forward position
um the Cavs have never been super
conventional in terms of you know player
size these past few seasons so overall I
think this was a great job by uh both
sides I think that this is a trade that
a lot of people are going to look at you
know down the line and talk about how
insane it was like it completely crashed
my app
um and I don't know about y'all I just
kind of thought he was going to end up
as a Nick instead he ends up as a
Cleveland Cavalier Utah Jazz heading
towards their rebuild if I had to give
kind of a
if I had to give somewhere where I
thought the Cavs would be this upcoming
season I think they could end up as like
a five seed I think that they're able to
you know they're able to make kind of
that run have young Talent grow develop
and potentially pass some of these older
teams in the Eastern Conference
um yeah so I think that they've done a
great job I'm excited for this for both
sides
um if we head back over to uh let's see
we've got
a I believe we've got a pretty clean
Jersey swap coming up now um which is
still weird because I don't I can't
really imagine Donovan Mitchell in a
Cavs Jersey like yet at all
um here it is we've got Mobley Mitchell
Garland let me know how it looks I think
it looks pretty good I think it looks
kind of natural
um I think that these three guys you
know them alongside Jared the fact that
jiren Allen isn't even in this jersey
swap like just shows how talented this
Cavs like big four is now they have the
potential to be ridiculous it's gonna be
it's gonna be insane
um we've got chirpy saying imagine
having to live in Utah now
um the Jazz will be back they will be
back it's going to be a few years
they'll be back
um we've got El Wills saying they still
not beating the Heat Bucks or Sixers or
Celtics in a seven game series I I mean
they could make some noise I really
think teams aren't going to want to play
them they were really good last year
prior to this whole situation you know
prior to injuries the Cavs are one of
the better teams in the Eastern
Conference if I remember correctly they
were up towards the top like three four
teams in the East for a good bit this
season like they were doing an
incredible job and now they add Donovan
Mitchell who can play make he can create
shots for others Mobley can take a jump
Garland can keep getting better uh Jared
Allen Kevin Love Off the Bench he was
really incredible with Ricky Rubio can
come back to anything like the form he
was at it's a really good team uh Fred T
says think they can beat the Bulls in a
seven game series I think they could
um obviously with the balls depends on
health you know got Lonzo ball if he's
back if both teams fully healthy though
that would be one hell of a series I
would love to see how that goes
um Garland Lonzo ball Donovan Mitchell
Zach Levine now I really want I really
want to see this series I appreciate you
uh putting that in my mind because now
I'm thinking about all the playoff
matchups you know seeing like the
backward of Garland and Donovan Mitchell
going up against like Maxi and Hardin
would be so fun to watch
uh gosh I'm really excited about this
Cavs team uh Justin Bailey says Donovan
looks crazy in that Jersey should be in
New York this hurts Don Mitchell looks
it looks really natural I'm surprised I
thought it would take a lot longer for
me to kind of get used to this but it
looks really natural
um you know I thought like I really
didn't expect it to go that kind of
crazy yeah
um uh the Ian Evans says not gonna lie
spider looks cleaning that Jersey
completely right I think
um it's a it's a really fun uh Trio big
four that they've got with Jared Allen
really fun young team uh I think that
it's it's got to be exciting to be a
cast fan if you're a Cavs fan out there
like
like very excited for you I think it's
gonna be really good uh the jerseys are
hideous but that's a fun Squad I don't
think so I think these are fine I like
these Cavs jerseys
um you know if we want to talk about
horrible jerseys and we're talking about
a team that we already talked about we
can go back to the Utah Jazz jerseys but
I'll spare you from having to look at
those because I wouldn't want to myself
uh but we'll go ahead and wrap things up
with that I appreciate y'all tuning in
um like I said my name is Cohn you know
do stuff on Twitter three underscore
cone on uh Twitter there YouTube tube
just three cone a podcast about the
Thunder 2 topic Thunder podcast you know
I talk about basketball sometimes really
excited to get the chance to talk with
y'all I appreciate y'all tuning in it
was a lot of fun uh this trade is
ridiculous and fingers crossed up
there's more chaos before the season
because you know didn't get the Katie or
Kyrie trade so let's look forward to
more chaos as usual with the NBA I
appreciate y'all and I'll see y'all
later